we shot it down and of course I'm
sitting here behind the desk in the Oval
Office but John summers with John Bolton
you're there yeah there's no question
that this was an Iranian drone and the
USS boxer took it out as the president
announced yesterday because it posed a
threat to the ship and its crew is
entirely the right thing to do people in
the world with the greatest equipment in
the world we have the greatest ships
most deadly ships we don't want to have
to use them but they're the most deadly
ships ever conceived
and we are not we hope for their sake
they don't do anything foolish they do
they will pay a price like nobody's ever
paid a price
you